this is a really important thing to  understand about scientology  you become  so dependent upon what Hubbard says is  the answer that you lose your  perspective on figuring things out for  yourself because it's easy and it's it's  actually frankly one of the things that  keeps people in Scientology it's really  easy in some respect while it's  enormously difficult in some fashion  it's really easy in some respects to be  a Scientologist you don't have to think  about anything there is an answer for  you on how to do everything and how to  act and what your reaction should be and  what you should think about things  everything like that